now i know it's a very tough decision
buying a tablet and i know people are
split 50 50 between
android and apple so today we're going
to break down
the two best devices from each category
to make it simple for you guys to make
your choice
if you're a samsung viewer looking for a
samsung tablet anywhere along the
timeline down here you'll find the
samsung review
if you're an apple fanboy and looking
for the best apple tablet
anywhere along the timeline over here
you'll find the apple review
so let's get started with samsung and
we're looking at the two devices
one the most expensive and premium and
two the lower lower budget end
we're going to be able to tell which one
the best is out of these samsung devices
pretty quickly
and it is unfortunate that it is the
higher end model so we're going to be
comparing the a7 tablet
and the s7 tablet the s7 tablet being
the more premium
version than the a7 the a7 can come in
anywhere from about 400 to 600 dollars
whilst the s7 comes in at a whopping
2 000 at its premium price tag
but if you want to get into the intro
version of the s7 it is still about 1200
australian dollars
so the s7 is significantly more
expensive but for a reason
if you've ever used a cheaper samsung
tablet you know that they are absolute
garbage
after the first year they start to slow
down and they become
unresponsive the s7 tablet is hopefully
not a device that you will be able to
see those sorts of results with it is a
premium tablet
it's like their samsung premium phones
and they last a very long time
thankfully
between these two devices the a7 only
comes with three gigabytes of ram
whilst the s7 comes with six from an
architectural point of view it's
important that these tablets have a
number of
elements one fast ram to be able to
determine and read
all the drawings that we need to bring
up two fast charging because we run out
of battery
so often and you're gonna be using it
quite often if you do buy one
and three s pen support or any type of
pencil support
is mandatory in my personal opinion so
between the two devices the s7 comes
with six gigabytes of ram the a7 comes
with three
the a7 only has 15 watt charging
whilst the s7 has 45 watt fast charging
and at the end of the day they both
support s pens so to break down
those three categories alone leaves you
with
the simple decision that the s7 is a
much
better device for what we do you're
going to be able to open up pdfs a lot
smoother a lot quicker
the hertz refresh rate screen on the s7
is going to be absolutely premium and
you're going to be able to see all those
small details when you zoom in
the a7 on the other hand only has a 60
gigahertz screen so it is significantly
more blurry
when you're looking at those finer
details overall we're looking at double
if not
triple the price of the a7 to the s7
in order to actually get what you need
as an architect
unfortunately we do use quite a bit of
ram and we do require
quite a bit of power from the tablet if
you're just using it for notes and
general markups the a7 is probably fine
but be wary that it's not going to last
too long and you will have to upgrade
relatively quickly if you're looking for
a tablet that will last a lot longer
as long as it doesn't have any faults
you don't drop it blah blah blah the s7
is a much much better product on top of
that you'll also get the added benefit
of the s7 having the ultra wide camera
of 5 megapixels now i know this doesn't
sound like much
and having an ultra wide camera isn't
the be all end all however using an
ultra wide camera in an architectural
setting
is basically all we do i run an s20
ultra
right now day to day and it is by far
the best
feature of the phone having an ultra
wide and going onto site and being able
to take a full
120 degree field of view is fantastic
so having that added extra on your
tablet means you don't have to pull out
your phone
and take that extra photo and then merge
them and figure them all out later on
you can take it all on that one device
so that isn't a deal breaker but it is
definitely an added benefit of the s7
now when it comes down to apple we have
a much more even battle on our hands
we have the apple air that has just been
released and redesigned
and the apple ipad pro now both of these
devices are phenomenal
both of them will be able to do the job
unlike the samsung comparison
there isn't unfortunately a medium
competitor that's able
to keep up with the s7 so in the apple
world we have both of these devices
which do fantastic things but there is
some key points that you need to be
aware of
now when selecting a tablet as an
architect you have to keep in mind
what we actually do with a tablet you're
going to be bringing up drawings
bringing up videos bringing up 3ds
and you're going to be taking a lot of
notes you're going to be sketching and
marking up all over drawings
and maybe if you're artistic you're
going to be able to draw and replicate
some beautiful 3d
hand sketch renders so the device has to
be
pretty powerful to be able to run this
the battery has to be pretty good
and in my personal opinion the screen
has to be perfect
because if you're going to look at
something all day you're going to want
the screen to be as best as possible
to make sure that your eyesight stays as
good as possible for as long as possible
so the brand new apple ipad air comes
with the new a14 chip whilst the apple
ipad pro comes with the old
a12 zip between these two the ipad air
is
more powerful than the ipad pro but
overall they're pretty much similar for
what we do you don't need any more
powerful than
these two devices neither one features
fast charging but the ipad air has 20
watt charging versus 18 watt
on the ipad pro the difference comes
down to price and budget the ipad air
costs nine hundred dollars to about
fourteen hundred dollars
whereas the ipad pro starts at fourteen
hundred dollars and goes all the way up
to entire two thousand dollar mark
if you need an ipad pro this is a very
large price tag to pay when the ipad air
is just as good
so what is the key element that i'm
really worried about between these two
devices
well the ipad air only has a 60
gigahertz refresh rate
whilst the ipad pro has a 120 hertz
refresh rate
i know it isn't the be-all end-all but
120 hertz
is so much different i personally have
an ipad air
and we have ipad pros at work the ipad
pros are so much cleaner
so much nicer and just an overall better
experience as an architect
the pencil is super responsive on both
so that isn't a comparative factor
but the screen resolution in itself just
makes that device
the clear winner and just like the s7
the ipad pro has that ultra wide camera
that lets you capture those
architectural angles in the ipad
straight away you're not needing to pull
out your phone and take
two different devices to be able to
capture what you need
so overall the ipad pro has those slight
slight advantages over the ipad air but
if you are on a budget
the ipad air is more than enough to be
able to do
what we do as architects in 2021 anyway
that's all from me today guys thank you
so much for watching i hope you enjoyed
the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below
like i already mentioned 28 videos in 28
days so it's a full-on
busy month there's lots of giveaways
here and there but you have to be
subscribed to win them
now it is usually i'll see you next
monday but being february
i will see you tomorrow